all right so in this series we're going
to talk about proteoglycans
glycosaminoglycans and glycoproteins so
here we'll just introduce them so let's
start off with proteoglycans so what are
they well they are panel they sound like
they are glycans with pro do okay so
basically there are mostly carbs with
some protein right they are black hands
but they've got some pro do okay so they
are mostly carbs mostly carbohydrates
plus some protein component okay so the
basic structure specifically is a bunch
of hetero polysaccharide chains
specifically called glycosaminoglycans
gly costs amino glycans plus a core
protein and there are also sometimes
linked proteins okay
like ostomy no black hands are also just
abbreviated as G a G right gags or MPS's
or mucopolysaccharides okay there used
to be called mucopolysaccharides due to
their presence and mutual secretions
okay and as far as the characteristics
of these hetero polysaccharide change we
should know some of them these hetero
polysaccharide chains a hetero meaning
different poly referring to many sakurai
being sugars so they are are long chains
of sugars okay and they are linear they
are unbranched okay they're often very
negatively charged and they contain a
repeating disaccharide unit okay and so
the these are just the header the the
glycosaminoglycans
and so the effect also means black hands
are connected to a core protein and
oftentimes there are linked proteins as
well so a pretty of Lycans structures
looks kind of like a bottle brush
quote-unquote or a test tube cleaner or
if you guys have straws at home that
that are reusable a lot of times they
look something like this there where
this portion represents this little rod
like structure here is a the core
protein and
these the portions in white there are
there by costuming of like ends those
are the linear hetero polysaccharides
alright so there's a bunch of different
sugars connected to each other in these
repeating that saccharide units they're
very negatively charged we'll talk more
about their the kind of structure and
function relationship later once we
learn a little bit more about this stuff
but as far as generally what their
functions are where proteoglycans
functions are is that there are major
component of the extracellular matrix
the extracellular matrix sometimes just
abbreviated as ECM
okay into the extracellular matrix and
really proteoglycans which of course
contain these PAGASA mean alike and
they're meant for a structural support
for cells and tissues and they're also
important in cell cell communication and
adhesion okay so that's generally what's
going on with pretty alike hands
now what about glycoprotein
you